[Music]
what's up man what's up Matt
hey man you know it's crazy did you just
met Nathan McMasters actually he's a
close friend of mine yesterday life is
crazy yes um I know you want me to be
quick just how to fight through the
[ __ ] and just be successful every
day
okay so let's define your [ __ ] like
what's your [ __ ] parents work boss
failed businesses your own head what's
your [ __ ] my [ __ ] right now man
I'll just finish my GED and get into the
army right now okay so that's is that a
process like that doesn't sound like
[ __ ] that sounds like something in
front of you that what you don't like it
like you you just hate school the way I
did and so just even getting the GED is
a pain in the ass but once you get done
with it you're pumped cuz then it gets
you into the army because then you're
able to get what you want from the army
yeah I mean my plan is I'll try to do a
two-year listen with the army and then
trying to use my GI Bill to pay for our
acting school who has to end all goal is
to try to get their act in some way so
this is where strategy really matters my
question is for some reason and normally
Society and parents you've decided
acting school is the best way for you to
become an actor in a world where many
actors become actors without going to
acting school yeah like my question is
instead of getting a GED and going to
the Army and then going to acting school
and spending the four and a half years
before you even get in that bat what
about making skits on Instagram and
YouTube with your homies or just going
to LA and just hanging around actors and
making skits - then get discovered to
become an actor yeah let's talk about it
let's talk about it this is why I
decided to take these seven minutes like
I'm here with you brother just mean you
so like have you put school on a
pedestal as the Gateway to get become an
actor because so many people in 2019
don't go to acting school to become an
actor and I'm like [ __ ] he's
giing it to [ __ ] get into the Army
Army's no [ __ ] joke you got to do the
army then that helps you pay for acting
school that's another I mean we're
talking about four and a half years
before you know before you even get an
at-bat and as I'm alive my man hammy
underscore TV right like this leaving
comedy goes you'll get that gig having
millions on social media more than
acting school now he's talented and him
and his fiance are making really great
videos sexually least you know but like
appropriate for Instagram but just you
know PG not PG not 30 migrate it are
something but nonetheless Mike this is a
very important question why school to
become an actor in your brain answer
that for me because I just feel like
that's kind of what I've been like
that's kind of just like I was in school
like you go to school the high school to
college I feel like that's just kind of
the route that works you know I feel
like that's kind of what I've been
taught and singing in front of me is how
that works and when I spit the concept
of Instagram and YouTube and just go
into LA and being a waiter and
networking with people that make content
and then if you've got the talent you've
got it you get discovered does that
sound like an alternative does that
sound crazy does that sound like a
lottery ticket like how does that sound
see like to me that just sounds like
something I could get immersed in you
know it's just like I don't know if I
get that sound laughing all to me that
sounds you know that sounds may be
actually how you're supposed to do it
now more so than you know 10 15 years
ago that sounds like something that is
what exactly happen to know you know so
what makes you then not want to are you
a family of military and you want to do
the army thing are you doing the army
thing because you don't want to go in
debt in acting school like talk to me
anything
yeah it's go like that like I mean my my
grandpa wasn't worrying like my dad was
in the Army you know and like when my
mom my freshman and sophomore well I
can't I rediscovered myself my freshman
and sophomore year high school
you know I was kind of like a jock and
you know and I kind of went life about
that way you know I played basketball
football and then once our grades start
to slip in and I couldn't play sports no
more I was like you different and you
know I can just see how people change
like they're you know just help quick
stuff can change for you and so I think
they're not kind of flipping to knock a
deep depression but you know as I've
grown up I've seen how kind of stupid
maybe I been so what allowed myself to
be at such a little point because of
that you're not stupid you're just a
human feelings or feelings like you
valued yourself based on other people's
opinions about you and when you weren't
an athlete people's opinions about you
changed yeah now my biggest question
whose opinions do you value for real
like like think about the like the math
around us ever having this phone call
it's low so let's let's be truthful here
straight-up whose opinions do you value
our price their value only a few people
you know who my family my girlfriend who
in your family your girlfriend who my
father my mom my grandfather my
girlfriend Ashley awesome so let's break
it down
I would assume based on what you just
told me that your father and grandfather
think it's a good idea for you to go to
the army yeah my biggest question is do
you think that or do you think that
because they think that I mean as just
like a foundation aspect of it I believe
it will be but do you think you can get
that foundation somewhere else I mean
yes I do I believe I'm where well maybe
there's like just like you said you know
just like just keep cracking out and
maybe found myself in LA or something
like that doing something maybe working
some minimum-wage job or whatever let's
talk about it do you think that your
parent your father and grandfather
specifically would be devastated if
you're like listen change of plans
I want to be an actor and what I think
is now the
way to do that is to just go to LA and
make content on YouTube and Instagram
and give myself two years minimum wage
living humbly as [ __ ] but living out my
dream to even see if I've got it know
that I don't think they would leave it
as you know I'm saying I think they
would be what they would want more so
it's just me to be safe and be able to
pay my bills I don't think it would be
something to wear they're extremely
disappointed well it sounds like you
have a great grandfather and father then
yeah that's me I mean obviously it would
be you know they would fight rather me
go in she'll be rather versus be
devastated or two very different things
you know my man there's so many ways to
[ __ ] do it
ya know I ran a liquor store for 11
years really 11 years 11 years my path
to Instagram and YouTube subscribers
does not look like most yeah if you want
to be an actor if you're asking one
man's point of view and I can be a
hundred percent wrong the thought that
GED to army to acting school feels less
right then going to Los Angeles working
at that Burger and DMing every single
influencer that makes content for them
to have you in their skits yeah well
that sounds that sounds good to me man
yeah that's just all about that no
nothing's the way I think to sometimes
the court case everything's about the
way you think this whole games the way
you think the world's about how you
think perspective is the [ __ ] jam
like seeing [ __ ] in your head is the
life it's the difference between
happiness and sadness it's the
difference between success and failure
everything's about how you think that's
why I'm [ __ ] sitting here on the
phone with you eight minutes and 40
seconds right now to give you a scene to
think about a different maybe yeah I
mean that's this is where I would like
like where do I start even how they get
over there like I don't know nobody over
there [ __ ] bus yeah well I live in LA
I live okay oh yeah take a bus take a
train drive hitchhike or take a plane
sell us you got some dumb [ __ ] in your
closet sell it on eBay and buy plane
ticket yeah go on Craigslist and find a
roommate yeah I know it's possible of
course it's possible millions of people
do it the question is are you hungry
enough and willing to [ __ ] eat [ __ ]
or are you soft no I believe them I
believe I'm willing to do it because I
know following you down here that you
know eat [ __ ] and I feel like people
that you know unless maybe they got a
stroke of just complete luck you know
that's what they at least have to eat
[ __ ] a little bit everybody ain't my man
every single person that's made it they
made it they ate [ __ ] and did the work
there's people that inherited money
there's people that have won the lottery
let's stop thinking about those people
everybody spends all their time thinking
about those people those people are
enigmas they're anomalies they're two
point zero zero zero zero one percent
they have nothing to do with you yeah
the 99.999 that made something of
themselves ate [ __ ] they put in the work
you're I know I'm right everybody's
fixated on [ __ ] 4,000 people while
there's seven point seven billion people
who [ __ ] worked or didn't and then
failed you want to be an actor get your
ass to [ __ ] LA yeah what do you mean
is there a star you don't know anybody
[ __ ] of course you know somebody
tweet and Instagram right now be like
who's in LA you know who's in LA your
former teammates [ __ ] sister your
[ __ ] friend from high schools uncle
people are no way you know [ __ ] 30
people in LA you I'm [ __ ] asked yeah
I know you're a mess yeah here I did I
know I'm right dude and I wanted for you
I appreciate that and the best part is
you might suck [ __ ] adapting but you
need to find that out yeah get your
[ __ ] North Carolina ass to LA take
Ashley with you and [ __ ]
go live your [ __ ] life don't [ __ ]
buy into an antiquated process you can
act tomorrow your I know I'm right
now are you scared to find out that you
suck at acting that's a different mental
game well I feel like I would be
mentally prepared for because I don't
wanna I don't think I would suck and
that's kind of maegor the school trying
to come into play but I mean I just know
that you know for a few years now I've
been Kyle just been so interested in
America I'm ending with this cuz I gotta
go scratch that itch scratch that itch
that you're interested cuz you don't
want to live with regret one day and say
[ __ ] when I was 20 I wanted to know if I
was an actor and I ended up not being an
actor because the military took me a
different route and I ended up this like
go scratch that itch this is exactly
when you can afford to be high risk
because you're young enough that you can
[ __ ] eat sonic burgers all day long
and like [ __ ] like Roman nuclear
romaine or whatever the [ __ ] what's that
[ __ ] called Roman nubile noodles and
ramen like [ __ ] you this is when you
do it and by the way I'm gonna save this
live stream I'm gonna end it right now
I'm gonna post it you can re-watch it
and [ __ ] 50 people invited you to
crash on her couch during this stream so
rewatch it click on their [ __ ]
Instagram handle DM and be like I'm
coming dude you need to be in yes
culture not in overthinking all the
variable culture yeah perspective yeah
well most people do a ton of [ __ ] to
protect themselves from ever finding out
their truth
you're fine with truth 100% you're
putting [ __ ] in school and then army and
then school again on a pedestal all to
not allow yourself to find your truth
yeah I know man
failure is what scares people
that's true get on scared my man sorry
but it is see ya love you see ya good
luck
[Music]
[Applause]